soyez sur les écrans connectés parce que
c'est possible aussi d'ailleurs on le
fait régulièrement avec tiphaine pour
aller chercher les sélections livre
aujourd'hui on s'intéresse à nos chers
voisins pour nos enfants et nos petits
enfants
pourquoi nos chers voisins mais parce
que tout le monde a des voisins
finalement et les enfants sont les
premiers à dire bonjour à tout le monde
là vous nous avez réellement à discuter
avec mamie avec les copains et là je
vous emmène dans la maison de briques de
pau la chair et stan mac publié à la
joie de lire et dans cette maison
figurez vous qu'ils habitent trois
familles des danseurs aussi une
chanteuse et un hibou solitaire line
dont j'ai vu des souris des petits
cochons des chats des ours des
kangourous et pas manchot est peut-être
n'ont-ils bout un vieux il répété voilà
mais plutôt conciliant quand même alors
pour faire cohabiter tout ce monde là
évidemment ce n'est pas très facile
parce que les doux comme en sol et
source commence la ribère nation
les artistes veulent répéter et les
souris craignent plus que tout chose de
se faire manger par le ch a vaincu donc
on essaye de trouver comment les faire
cohabiter alors on fait des ménages et
les ans les autres dans l'album
donc ça donne un petit effet comique et
finalement on se rend compte à la fin
que c'est facile de cohabiter si chacun
y met du sien
alors c'est un album plutôt pour les
petits évidemment à partir de 4 ans mais
c'est plutôt un message positif voilà
parenthèse sur la cohabitation parce que
je me sentais très attentifs et tonio
forcément en internat pour cohabiter
avec ses camarades de jeu il faut
forcément y mettre aussi un petit peu du
sien aux vêtements c'est tout à fait ça
j'ai que chacun y mette du sien un peu
comme ça pour l'ensemble pour le groupe
ouais alors il ya différents groupes
là on l'a vu il ya différents immeubles
aussi il n'y a pas que des enfants
citadins il ya ya ya pas que des
immeubles voisinage ne se limite pas aux
immeubles ça peut être parfois même à
tout un quartier
oui voilà et qui fait le lien dans un
quartier est ce que vous avez une idée
pascal alors le lien dans le quartier
baisser le chef
mais non ces facteurs abbaoui vaillance
et l'équipe - envoi des facteurs ces
bourses oui mais c'est lui qui peut
rentrer entrouvrir la porte et voir ce
qui s'y passe
alors pour découvrir le travail du
facteur il yal enveloppes mystérieuses
d'arthur le facteur de jeu
moncomble les publier aux éditions
format et donc on en trouvera comme ça
les portes des différents voisins alors
il ya hortense qui collectionne les
faire-part il ya mamie qui se fait lire
le journal qui négocie avec le facteur
pour qu'ils passent toujours un peu plus
de temps chez un sacré décolleté
magnette reprendre sa tournée il fil
rouge entre ces différents personnages
et bien ces sept enveloppes mystérieuses
que le facteur essaye de remettre à la
famille figueras mais personne ne
connaît cette famille alors je vais pas
vous donner lâche écrit finalement pas
grâce aux facteurs des gens vont se
rencontrer vont faire connaissance et
bien c'est comme ça qu'on entretient un
bon voisinage à partir de 5-6 ans et
puis c'est assez sympa parce qu'à la fin
il ya des petits autocollants pour
personnaliser ces enveloppes
et puis se remettre à écrire et à
récrire hammami par exemple ça c'est
bien
s'il ya des facteurs savez c'est bien et
didon à propos de ça alors maintenant
avec les mails et téléphone portable et
tout et tout les internes ils reçoivent
plus de courrier très peu très peu
d'accords de lettres d'amour de vacances
par exemple
nous avons eu le mérite moi vous ne
verrez pas le courrier comment n'y a pas
de filtre alors allez on continue dans
nos albums avec tiphaine pour cet autre
album cette fois ci on va s'intéresser
aux quartiers aux voisins est un poète
que vous aimez particulièrement oui
s'appelle carl norac c'est un poète
belge je sais pas si vous le connaissez
mais les codes du tout pas mal des
petits poèmes pour les enfants alors il
est parfois il étudie à l'école et se
livrent la rue d amour édité par à pas
de loup propose est bien aussi
d'entretenir la porte et d'aller chez
les voisins mais par le regard d'une
enfant qui vous dis qu'est la vie dans
une rue grise d'une ville grise alors ça
commence mal on se dit mais ça va pas
être très intéressant mais cette petite
ville à elle a le chic pour regarder un
peu plus loin derrière les apparences et
elle vous montre que finalement et bien
tous ses voisins ou quelque chose un
univers un monde à l'intérieur et qui
est assez coloré finalement il ya une
couturière et un clown il ya vous le
voyez cette fille de l'atlas qui a tout
temps
à raconter et alors je voulais vous
proposer ce livre parce qu'il est un
petit peu à part pour les enfants à
partir de 8 ans et puis qu'il va
peut-être leur donner envie de se dire
que leurs voisins ont aussi peut-être
des choses à partager
juste envie de voyager aussi très joli
dessin à la main bien pour terminer
l'été fun on va partir dans l'univers
des mangas
oui à tout à l'heure le pokémon
s'appelle mais les esprits il ya deux
tomes c'est de chéraute au riu chiots et
c'est édité parole doki doki
hélas alors comme le dit le titre les
voyants sont très encombrant ce sont des
esprits alors ça s'appelle les yôkai et
figurez vous que c'est une jeune
adolescente qui se retrouvent à les voir
mais elle sait pas trop comment traiter
avec eux puisque normalement c'était les
anciens qui savait comment parler aux
esprits et donc elle se retrouve un
petit peu dépassé c'est très sympa c'est
très gai je le conseille plutôt aux
adolescents évidemment et il ya déjà
deux tomes sont parus ces dames sont
plonge dans le surnaturel alors voilà
sans imaginer si les esprits en
débarquer chez vous savez parfait en
attend la suite avec impatience y en a
12 pts est le troisième mais jamais deux
sans trois pour l'année prochaine
peut-être hockey